one of the worst places in the world to
be right now from the standpoint of
coronavirus
is the u.s state of florida in total the
united states is one of the worst places
to be like if you look at just country
level data
but thankfully for now some states in
the united states are actually doing
pretty well but if you look in more
detail at the state by state data
there are some spots in the united
states that are the worst places to be
and that includes arizona that includes
texas that includes california
but certainly florida is one of those
places florida has 21 million people
that's more than many countries have if
florida were a country
it would be one of the countries with
the worst
outbreaks in the world right now in
terms of the growth rate of cases
florida republican state rep anthony
sabatini went on cnn
said florida is doing just fine now i'm
going to play some clips for you
he sounds completely delusional he
praised governor ron desantis
handling of the virus ron desantis the
florida republican governor
is engaged in a battle with georgia
governor kemp
and texas governor greg abbott for who
has had the absolutely worst
response the outbreak in miami is being
compared to the initial
outbreak in wuhan china dr lillian [ __ ]
said quote miami is now the epicenter of
the pandemic
what we were seeing in wuhan six months
ago five months
ago now we are there but anthony
sabatini doesn't care here he is by the
way
sabatini i feel like he's doing a
disservice to the sabbatini name
great argentinian tennis player gabby
sabatini and
anthony sabatini shows up on cnn and
tries to tell brianna keeler
that everything's fine in florida
brianna keeler tries to bring him back
to reality
well brian i think what you're doing is
what a lot of folks in the media have
done which is harped
exclusively on one metric namely the
cases
cases cases cases the media is almost
exclusively focused on this one number
versus
the two most important numbers obviously
hospitalizations and fatalities
where in most parts of the state
flatlined or gone down especially in
mine
so for now sabatini is just pushing the
talking point cases don't really matter
what matters is hospitalizations what
matters is deaths
but remember the cases are the earliest
indicator first you test positive
then you get sick enough to have to go
to the hospital
then some portion of those folks who go
to the hospital
die and case in point cases have been
exploding in florida since around june
26th that's like
20 days ago death started to spike a few
days ago
yesterday again florida set
a new single day death record and then
they did it again i mean multiple
new single day death records in florida
so deaths are spiking anthony sabatini
is pretending that they're not
but let's continue with the interview
and you're going to hear the state
the state rep from florida say florida's
doing fine and desantis is doing great
and so if we focus on the two more
relevant metrics
florida's doing just fine okay we focus
on case positivity and we just did a
report on the metrics that you cited
perhaps you didn't hear it
but you've had actually in leon county a
circuit judge who said
and look we checked representative we
checked with constitutional experts
who said and this is what the court
judge said and this this is what the
circuit judge said
and constitutional experts agree with
this the ordinance because you lost in
leon county the ordinance has a quote
valid basis to protect public health
because
i mean you talk about this being an
extraordinary circumstance but we are in
an extraordinary circumstance we're in a
pandemic
and florida's not doing just fine
no they are but on the judge issue
there's about 800 circuit court judges
no you think florida is doing
you think florida is doing fine right
now absolutely i think the governor's
response has been
on point and i think that the metrics
that matter the most
we're doing very well and if you're
counting cases you're going to scare
people but what they don't realize is
okay cases are yes far less four
thousand
five hundred twenty one total cases
three hundred one thousand
last week hospitalizations increasing 19
334 54 hospital icus
have reached capacity in florida another
40 hospitals
show that icu's are at 10 or less
availability well let me remind you you
say you're doing issues
we're the we're the nation's third
largest state so out of the 70 000 new
cases we had last week
we had about 100 more people go to the
hospital that is a
extremely small number when you're
looking at the fact that we have 21
and a half million people certainly not
the sort of numbers that would drive
people to shut down the economy
you're the epicenter of a global
pandemic and you can't even admit that
that's actually a false assessment
entirely uh
uh i don't even know what you mean by uh
epicenter
notice that this is not about math we
like to think sometimes on the left
naively that if we just show them the
numbers everybody's going to get on the
same page
everybody will understand what's going
on everybody will agree just show them
the numbers
but it doesn't work and yesterday we
spoke to dr christopher de carlo
about critical thinking and about data
and statistics and
it just doesn't work that way and part
of the reason it doesn't work that way
is you have people like anthony sabatini
and donald trump
just saying things that aren't based in
fact going around saying florida's fine
we're not the epicenter there's nothing
to see here reality doesn't matter
now on top of this we also have to
remember
we have much reason to think that we
aren't even really getting the true
numbers
out of florida we go back about a month
six weeks there were already allegations
that florida was covering up or
misreporting
data now officially as of two days ago
the trump administration says
stop reporting to the cdc instead report
your data
to hhs and alex azar trump tool alex
azar who at one point
hired a labradoodle breeder to deal with
the day-to-day of coronavirus that was
early on
so even with the numbers we're getting
out of florida florida's deaths have hit
new single day records multiple times in
the last week
the last week in total has been the
worst week for florida in terms of cases
in terms of deaths
but remember that on the tail end of
this the real data might be even worse
florida is the epicenter of the global
pandemic at this point in time
and part of the reason why is they
insist everything's completely fine
it's like the naked gun scene with the
great comedic actor leslie nielsen
where he's saying please disperse
nothing to see here please disperse
and a building is exploding in the
background many of you know the scene
it's been the subject of a lot of
memeing on the internet
that's essentially what anthony sabatini
is doing here and it's absolutely
insane absolutely and utterly insane
i'm going to be talking a lot more about
this
in the next few weeks but i want to sort
of
get us thinking about this we are now
past the point of no return with
coronavirus
in terms of the timing of the election
let me explain
what i mean by that um it takes
somewhere in the range of eight to ten
weeks to flatten the case curve
if you lock down today right which means
that
if florida arizona these states that are
imploding if they did a full lockdown
today you would probably not see the
effect of that
you wouldn't see the cases come under
control until october 1st
but in addition to that deaths lag by 20
days
so if we saw a lockdown today
you wouldn't really see some of these
states get the outbreak under control
until late october okay so when you know
that when you see
15 000 cases a day in florida death
records in florida
the timeline of how the virus works we
saw it in new york we know how long it
takes
it means that there will be a huge
coronavirus problem in some of these key
states including florida which will be
so important for the november election
it's going to be going on in mid-october
in the best case scenario and that's if
states lock down they don't even seem
interested in locking down what that
tells us
is trump can't rely on winning in
november
because the virus is under control just
mathematically it's not going to happen
this means they only have dirty tricks
left
and andy kroll wrote a really good
article in rolling stone
outlining the techniques that
republicans and trump are going to use
to try to win
one technique is going to be using
lawsuits to wreak havoc in february the
trump campaign
as andy crow writes and the republican
national committee announced
they were going to spend 10 million
dollars filing voted voting-related
lawsuits in 2020. in pennsylvania for
example
they sued the state government of
pennsylvania and election boards in
every county
to ban the use of secure drop boxes for
submitting
take-home ballots and they said that
poll watchers can only serve in the
county where they live
which is a great way to if you have a
county without a highly engaged
population
you would want to bring in poll watchers
from other counties that won't be
allowed it's a great way to allow
intimidation at the ballot box they're
going to be working to block ballots
including
ballots submitted by mail they're going
to be working on intimidating voters
they will be spreading disinformation
they're going to be working to prevent
absentee ballot expansions altogether
and we've seen donald trump doing that
for months already
they're going to use bogus fears of
voter fraud to justify
whatever they can get away with so none
of these techniques are
new but the point is they don't have
any more the idea of hey you know what
our strategy will be we'll do a little
voter suppression because we always do
it
but we'll also make a case that we have
dealt with the virus and we fix the
economy
trump sort of still continues to claim
that he's dealing with the virus well
but the math of it shows a different
reality and
the cases are going to be raging for
eight to ten weeks in the best case
scenario in some of these states so all
they have left are the dirty tricks
i'm going to be doing much more
extensive coverage of this and my goal
is
we all need to be prepared for what they
are likely to do we need to expect
what they are going to do we need to
have a plan to fight it
we are going to be talking about how you
can get involved as an election monitor
i mean there are things
depending on state laws that you can
actually do and get involved in
but this has to be our focus now because
they're out of actual policy arguments
trump hasn't even talked about policy in
any way for weeks other than saying
we're going to do more of the great
stuff in the second term that i did in
the first term even though it didn't
really happen in the first term
and in any case it's the fault of the
coronavirus or democrats or obama or who
jimmy carter i mean he'll blame anybody
right
all they have left their dirty tricks
and that's why this is so important
make sure you're following me on twitter
at d pacman for the latest updates on
all of this we're going to take a quick
break and it's just a beautiful friday
show for you today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
welcome back to the show today's new
members of the day are caitlin hernandez
and erin leaths caitlin and aaron thank
you so much for your support
also a huge thank you to leslie thurman
who has been a member for almost
five years and is today's long time
sustaining member of the day
grab a membership get the daily bonus
show the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
and just a good feeling deep down inside
that you're supporting
alternatives to homogenous corporate
media
let's go to the phones at 617-830-4750
starting today with our caller from the
214
area code who's calling today from 214.
hello david this is dave from dallas hey
dave yeah i can what's going on now
we're not on speaker are we
uh you know what you're on my bluetooth
man hang on
all right not bad sorry
what's on your mind yeah it's okay
okay uh thanks for taking my call a few
weeks ago
a few weeks ago you were asking an
audience question about whether the
economy does better under democrats
or republicans right and you mentioned
so you mentioned several metrics stock
market gdp
unemployment but there's another metric
you didn't mention which is
recessions i was born in 1958 and there
have been 11 recessions in my lifetime
one of them started when jimmy carter
was president the other kin
all started during republican
administrations
only one republican in my lifetime and
remember i'm 62 years old
right only one republican in my lifetime
gerald ford
who served less than two and a half
years didn't have a recession start
while he was president however thanks to
his republican predecessor
richard nixon we were already in a
recession when he took office
you're under 40 so every republican in
your lifetime
has had a number of recessions equal to
the number of terms they served
exactly they can't go four years without
causing a recession
seriously how do they maintain this
reputation for being better on the
account
are they just better at branding i think
so i mean yes that
so so it's all linked to the simplicity
of a lot of these ideas sort of like hey
i mean
you know taxes are your money and you
should keep it
and it must be better for the economy if
people keep the money they earn
so we're good with the economy right
it's like simple it's ideas that are
that simple that take hold
i just don't know how the american
people can be that easily fooled it's
just crazy
well we know they can because trump is
president
valid point man that's why i was
wondering my friend thank you very much
love your show all right dave from
dallas dave from dallas on fire shot out
of a cannon there and getting right into
his point i love it
um let's go next to our caller from the
954
area code who's calling today from 954
hello yeah who's this
hi this is um justin from uh george i'm
calling from
john's creek georgia hey justin
hi uh love your show um i had
two kind of two two questions so to
speak
the first the first concerning let's say
um best case scenario happens in
november we get when
joe biden joe biden defeats donald trump
resoundingly
we extend our joint we democrats expand
the majority in the house and take back
the senate
what are there any potential guard rails
or anything we can do to um uh
like prevent prevent trump and
mcconnell and the other republicans from
just going
going off the rails burning everything
down in the in the six week
in the 10 week 10 or 11 weeks between
election day and when biden is
inaugurated
well assuming you're not literally
meaning starting to burn things down
they can only really do so much i mean
trump will probably
if let's not put the cart before the
horse but if it gets to that point and
trump has that two and a half month lame
duck period
i think mostly trump would recede into a
shell
and blame everybody other than himself
for losing if that happens and might not
try to do that much but the things he
would likely do would include
um pardoning people uh executive orders
that he believes would either be digs at
obama or biden
or ways to get favors to his friends
but i i actually don't think that you
know the real concern would be do they
try to push
more judges through and
that is something that maybe democrats
would be able to prevent on the same
basis that mitch mcconnell prevented
merrick garland from getting to the
supreme court
i think if trump loses he's going to be
so distraught he won't be doing very
much during that lame duck period
uh i i certainly hope so i mean we i
mean we know that he's basically
i mean my hope is that the worst he does
is send some nasty some
petty tweets about how it was rigged or
how he was how he was treated unfairly
but it just was also that
empty threats yeah i mean the problem
about the tweets about
the the problem about tweets about the
election being rigged
is that as stupid as those would be
they likely would inspire some of his
followers
to potentially become violent and that's
something that
is potentially potentially very
problematic listen justin
i know you had a second question i'm
going to let you go because your
connection is is not great and we we
want to make sure that we can hear
everybody beautifully so i i will have a
lot of people holding i do want to get
to
let me go next to our caller from the
401
area code maybe our friendly neighbors
to the south in rhode island is that
possible
caller from 401 it sounds like you have
us muted but you are on
all right last chance for the caller
from 401 if you would like to unmute and
chat with me
all right that came and went let's go to
480 i believe 480
is arizona and given what's going on in
arizona i would very much want to talk
to somebody there
480. who's this where you calling from
yeah this is my name steve hey steve are
you calling from arizona
i am yeah i'm in phoenix actually what
on earth is going on there
uh actually that kind of had to do with
one of my questions
um uh actually i mean arizona is
actually the the raid is starting to
fall ever since ducey
reimposed those restrictions um
arizona has seen a decline over the past
week
and i kind of feel bad for ducey because
he gets it from
both sides the right and left because we
got a lot of right-wing nuts in arizona
um but that that kind of lends itself to
my question to you and that's
i've seen a lot of uh stuff on twitter
coming from the right about
corona viruses being reported two three
four times
they're insinuating that people are
going and getting tested and
uh showing up positive then they go to
another hospital and do it again
um have you have you seen these claims
and do they hold any water in your
opinion
well so so why would someone do that if
someone gets a positive test
at one hospital why would they go to
another hospital and
be tested again well they're saying
they're doing that
to increase the rate to make it seem
like there's more coronavirus
cases than they're actually yeah and i
mean i got you but so hold on steve
who when you say they individuals are
saying
i'm going to increase the rate by
driving around and getting multiple
tests or someone is coordinating
individuals who
once they find out here's someone with
the virus
let's call them and tell them to keep
getting tests at different hospitals who
is
they that is doing it yeah andy biggs
is uh he's one of our representatives he
he's spreading this information
kelly townsend um just
you know republican arizona lawmakers
that have no idea what's going on so
they spread this disinformation
right my question is my question is who
is
coordinating going who whose idea is it
to get a person who's sick to take
multiple tests
is it the person who's sick or is there
some person
on the left who is finding infected
people
and suggesting to them that they go get
more tests who's doing it
that's a good question they haven't said
that
because to me it's all bull crap yeah
yeah no listen i mean
that's patently absurd and um
you know but by the way it's not clear
that the numbers really are reversing in
arizona there was a decline over the
weekend but that's typical that over the
weekend you see fewer cases
the numbers from yesterday are are
absolutely brutal and i think already
today as we are speaking
arizona has again reported a hundred
deaths like it's actually i don't think
arizona has
turned anything around yet but yeah i
mean listen the more focused that there
is on conspiracy theories like
sick people are driving around getting
multiple tests the worse it's going to
get because that's not really going to
deal with the virus
no i know i know um i i had one more
question for you david if you don't mind
sure so trump has signed a lot of uh
executive orders
uh during his tenure um you know most
notably the paris accord and
uh my question to you is can you if joe
biden were to get elected
um would he be able to just kind of
reverse course and all that
and you know kind of undo what trump did
and do you think he will
there's a lot that can be in the same
way that it was done but
remember that a lot of the things obama
did trump undid by executive order
a lot of the things trump did by
executive order can be undone by the
next president and this is
you know a lot of times the debate about
executive orders is whether it's an
overreach of power or when
should or shouldn't an executive order
be the other very practical reality
is that a whole bunch of trump's
executive orders don't actually do
anything
and they're just a waste of time in the
sense that they it's an executive order
notifying mayors that they should
prioritize you know
xyz it doesn't really do anything the
ones that do something
can also very much be undone by the next
president
this is why we we really need to re this
is part of our broken system that it's a
lot of just
undoing what the previous person did and
it's a big waste of time for everybody
so you don't think him going back into
the paris accord will have much of an
effect
oh no no i'm saying you're saying uh if
biden comes in and says we're back in
the paris climate accord
right right oh no that that would be a
very good thing what i'm saying is
it can be easily changed by the next
president which i thought was your main
question yeah biden can change that
decision immediately
okay that's that's that was my main
concern that was probably the one thing
that trump's done that has
upset me the most um was the paris
accord but
uh hey man i really appreciate you
taking my call
i try calling all the time i never get
through so i appreciate it yeah yeah
thank you for continuing to try and uh
great to talk to you
and i hope to hear from you again as
well let's go
next to oh let's go to the caller from
last week from the 413
our old home area code who had such a
bad connection that we couldn't hear him
i didn't even get your name i thought
you said deshawn but i'm not even sure
if i got that right
hey david can you hear me now yes what
was your name
ishaan i'm calling from wallston
massachusetts
okay i had you as dashon all right
ishaan i've got that corrected thank you
yes yeah i go to um amherst um
so i have two questions for you both
related to immigration
um so did you hear about the trump
administration
making new policies about kicking out
one million
foreigners students f1 visa students of
the united states
in the name of coronavirus and in the
name of ina
and then yesterday they resended those
policies yes
after the major major um flashback and
um political blow by um mit harvard
lawsuits
and um top 10 giants and 18 states i
guess 18
students yes that is correct
i did hear about that that did happen
yeah so my question first question is i
i read on quora there are some
speculations people are saying that
trump basically did that because he was
worried about the mit lawsuit
and he might just since the exemptions
granted on march 13th say that
the exemptions are gonna continue as
long as we're in the state of national
emergency
trump might just say that the pandemic
is over and the
national emergency is over immediately
revoking all those exemptions and
putting all those 1 million students in
a state of like
chaos and hysteria and forcing them to
be out of the country
in the middle of the semester do you see
that as a possibility can you do that
it's certainly a possibility i think at
this point
anybody who is putting out a theory
that trump is thinking two or three
steps ahead
you're probably mistaken because trump
has not shown an ability to think two or
three steps ahead
i don't believe this is a super high
priority for donald trump
i think it's as simple as there was blow
back so he changed his mind about
kicking out the students
i don't think he's thought about it
beyond that
great okay yes that makes sense yeah
also because it's not just mit harvard
it was like 18 states his own people
were suing him so i don't think
he could do anything about it and then
it's like 42 billion dollars
coming in every year right so my second
question
is about what you said i guess one or
two months back
um you basically told us about um two
types of reform
which which happened one is burn the
system down
to the bottom and then build it up back
again and the second one you told about
is who wasn't make changes
as you are in the system without having
any
kind of wars and clashes and stuff like
that
so my question is regardless of what
happens to international students
regardless of what happens to um h1b
holders regardless of what
what happens to win card holders it's
pretty evident
from all of its executive orders and
even this um
policy fiasco and everything that
internationals are not welcome
in the united states so regardless of
whatever happens
so the message is clear his xenophobic
agendas are being promoted every day
so that i'm assuming that that means
that people are now gonna
people are not gonna see us in future as
as their dream destination
those 42 billion dollars might reduce to
i guess 20 billion next year
the next year 10 billion and then so
forth
and then the h-1b holders with some
people claim abusive system which is not
so true because
not all of them do that we have some um
um
we have some um hey ishan i'm sorry
ishaan i'm sorry to interrupt
i'm struggling to follow everything
you're saying did you have is there a
question in there for you said you had a
second question
yeah yeah it's a question i'm sorry for
making it so long my bad so my question
is if biden gets elected
if biden gets elected will he do
anything to work with the congress
about a major immigration reform
transfer
um converting it more towards a
merit-based approach
as in canada and australia or is it just
a promise he is making right now i mean
he's not very open about it but it does
stay in its website that
you can absolutely work with congress i
believe that that is joe biden's
intention as you know every presidential
candidate
has a long list of things that they say
they would like to do
only a fraction of them get done so yes
i believe that this is something joe
biden wants to do and we will see if he
does it
ishaan out of curiosity what kind of
phone are you using what are you on some
kind of device
special device or speaker or in a in an
under uh
uh i'm on the iphone right now um
normally using it i guess it's probably
because of the cards
um ah very going outside all right
thank you i'm so glad i was able to hear
your questions this time around we're
going to take a quick break if you're
holding
don't hang up we'll be right back after
this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as
one dollar per month or as much as you
want
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about them
welcome back to the david pakman show
let's get back to the phones at
zero 617-830-40 seven fifty you know who
has not called in
um for ten months it's been ten months
since we caught him live
it's furious trumpist jimmy from philly
let's see what's going on with jimmy
jimmy it it was september 24th the last
time you called in
are you in a welding facility
david yeah david yeah
i got a shot tomorrow what's up david
hey jimmy please please don't scream
into the phone it's very unpleasant
oh i'm sorry i'm around a lot of noise
let me get away
yeah please that nice i like that nice
quiet calm jimmy voice the quieter the
better yeah
yeah the one you never hear right
so so david i really don't have a
question i have a statement
uh one this whole coronavirus thing is
concocted by the chinese and the
democrats to get rid of trump
okay and two black lives matter is a
joke
they're based on if you read their
website they're based on trayvon martin
the guy who attacked an armed man and
lost jimmy jimmy i want to hear i don't
know hold on a second i don't want to
miss a second of what you're saying
you're so loud you've got to move the
phone like a foot from your mouth
okay you've got to move it like
literally move it 12 inches away
it's kind of hard i apologize yeah i
work around machinery i get loud too
so black lives matter you don't like
well i don't like them because they're
based on a lot okay what lies that
trayvon martin attacked attacked an
armed man and lost
and michael brown went for a cop's gun
and lost that one too
and and so this is this relates to what
jimmy what are you talking i don't know
what you're talking about so but so you
don't like black lives matter
no no i think it's a big lie i think uh
i think anybody who
demonstrates some kind of racial pride
is just showing their
uh stupidity oh i mean like
i'm not yeah okay all right and is is
black lives
hold on a second but jimmy is black
lives matter
a a racial pride group or is it a racial
equality
i would say so yes yes i would say so
i would say bring your children to
protest david how stupid is that
why would you bring a child to something
that could promote violence
i saw a bunch i saw a bunch of kids with
no masks
at the anti-mask anti-lockdown protests
too
yeah well you know it's funny how people
can't go to church and i'm an atheist
but uh
you know black lives matter can be out
there protesting no but hold on a second
jimmy because now you're saying
something different you you said black
lives matter is bad
because you saw kids at the protests but
what about the kids at the anti-mask
protests are you worried about that
no you're not and why not that doesn't
look damn it no nobody's happy when they
see black lives matter coming down the
street
okay you don't get a warm fuzzy feeling
did you get away did you get
did you get a warm fuzzy feeling from
the armed anti-mask protesters
intimidating law enforcement
i think they're idiots too dude sorry
what i don't see where they're going to
be armed why not just not wear the mask
but you know what david they have the
right to be on okay
but so did you get it but the question
was did you get a warm fuzzy feeling
from it
no absolutely not you didn't okay i
wouldn't have wasted
very good well it sounds like everything
are you off alcohol in on
lsd still or yeah yeah
yeah um i actually stopped drinking
tremendously i gotta drink a beer now i
can't even finish it
yeah ridiculous that is that's nice
what was one of them gay when i made the
gay joke about the politician
all right jimmy we're gonna let him go
uh when jimmy starts going homophobic we
do let him go
uh let's see who and what a connection
huh let's go to our caller from the 508
area code maybe a uh caller from the
boston area caller from 508 what's your
name where are you calling from
hello david yes uh this is toby from
massachusetts
toby how are you i'm doing good my
question to you
is um do you think republicans will be
on board with
abolishing the electoral college if they
lose an election
if or if they win the popular vote but
lose the electoral college
well so two answers to that first is
yeah probably they'll probably very
quickly change their mind if the
electoral college ends up hurting them
so republicans benefit from the
electoral college we have a number of
cases including
in 2016 where the republican candidate
lost the popular vote but won
electorally and that's part of why
republicans defend it
but it's extremely unlikely to happen
that's the reality and
uh that many republican presidents have
only won because
of the electoral college and i mean
listen in this november is an example
trump is not going to win the popular
vote the question is that he does he eke
out an electoral victory so i just don't
think we're going to see that anytime
soon i mean maybe you know in four or
eight years but
certainly this year biden if i were to a
betting man
i would bet on biden winning the popular
vote i don't know who's going to win
electorally
yeah because that's something i've been
thinking about i have to think about the
um
the national popular vote interstate
compact and i've been
i've been hoping that that is something
that gets through
in the near future even if it's not
likely because
the electoral college is such a broken
system yes
yeah so for people who don't know the
national popular vote interstate compact
what that is is essentially
states who say instead of awarding our
electoral votes to whoever wins our
state
will award them to whoever wins the
national popular vote if you get enough
states together to do that
such that the total of their electoral
votes is 270 which is the number
required for the presidency
you've effectively made a national
popular
vote the the legal question around it
is whether some states are not allowed
to do that and that's an issue that's
come up recently by state constitutional
law
uh and obviously you know i'm not a
lawyer my formal training is in podiatry
so i would not be able to answer that
i guess we lost toby there toby did toby
had enough with me
and toby hung up let's go next to
let's try the 774 area code sticking
again potentially with massachusetts
who's calling today from 774.
hi is this me yes it is hi
david uh so i'm trevor from worcester
trevor what's going on
um so i just wanted to ask you about
biden's environmental plan um
he put a bunch of different cool uh not
cool but
very uh progressive pieces into his
policy like establishing the
environmental and climate division in
the doj
and overhauling the epa external civil
rights compliance office and creating a
national crisis strategy and all that
stuff
um but what did baiden in your opinion
leave out of his plan
that maybe the progressives in his unity
group
wanted into the plan that he left out
you know you you'd have to ask them i've
only looked at a bulleted
summary so far i've not read through all
of it but certainly the biden plan
is not the green new deal the biden plan
is you know what i found good about the
biden plan
in terms of the summaries that i've read
is that
he's doing what he promised to do in
other words months ago joe biden said
i support the green new deal as a
framework with which
i will build a plan and will listen to
what the green new deal says and
consider other voices
and a lot of people said i don't believe
it i don't believe it i don't believe it
and the biden plan integrates some of
the milestones and guidelines of the
green new deal into a plan that to be
clear
is not the green new deal but what i'm
pleased by
is that first of all i mean listen again
biden is not an ultra progressive
if biden gets to do what he's proposing
it will be the most progressive
environmental plan in the history of the
united states now you're going to have
people who come out and say he'll never
get it done
well that's not unique to biden no
president gets everything done that they
say they want to do
you'll hear people come out and say
biden doesn't really believe this stuff
he's only saying it because he thinks it
will help him politically
you can say that about any candidate and
to some degree
it's always true but the idea that biden
is particularly dishonest about what he
wants
i've seen no evidence for so listen uh
if i do a full review i could come back
to you and say here's the five things
that aren't in it that should be
but overall i like that biden has stuck
to his word of using the green new deal
as a framework for putting together a
plan i'm pleased with it
hello trevor from i'm sorry i i missed
that last part i'm sorry
i'm i'm pleased overall that joe biden
has stuck to his word
and use the green new deal as a
framework for his plan
yeah i agree completely that the green
new deal is a great framework it should
be what we have
but this is definitely a great
alternative my second question really
quickly would be that
um do we need the electoral college in
order or rather
in order to implement ranked choice
voting into our voting system
do we need the electoral college in or
can we
should we get rid of it in order to
implement ranked choice voting you can
do right now
it's really two separate things i mean
listen if you go to national popular
vote
you eliminate electors per state and you
can
tally the national popular vote as first
past the post or ranked choice voting
single transferable vote etc that'd be
one path
the other path is you keep the electoral
college
but at the individual state level the
elections are held
using a ranked choice or alternative
voting system so these
a lot of people talk about doing both
together obviously it's incredibly
unlikely that you're going to get both
together nationally at the exact same
time but they don't have to both be done
together
okay awesome thanks for answering my
questions all right trevor thank you so
much for the phone call i very much
appreciate it
let me go next to our caller from the
203 area code who's calling today from
203
hello david can you hear me yes i can
who is this
uh so i am joe harris i'm from
connecticut which is
massachusetts but as only you would know
being from massachusetts it's next to
massachusetts no one else knows where it
is
connecticut is a great place it's a
great place where
um a lot of people who work in new york
city live in fact
yeah yes very that's why covid was a
little scary but now i'm out in
pittsburgh so less scary but anyway
my big question was as someone who's a
younger person
i'm not ex exactly excited about joe
biden but taking him as president would
obviously be better than trump
right on these down ballot races in the
senate do you think there's any way the
democrats could take the senate i see
like susan collins maine
maybe that um seat in montana and uh
arizona i think it's mark kelly or
something in arizona yep
but do you think there's any way we can
push 50 51
or is that unlikely oh no i mean listen
it's an up
i i if you said to me i have to it's a
even money bet
who do i bet keeps control i probably
bet
on republicans but there's a very clear
path for democrats and it
does include as you mentioned mark kelly
in arizona um
you've got corey gardner who who's
potentially facing defeat in colorado to
hickenlooper in fact it looks like
hickenlooper is going to win
we had some polling from montana that
says steve bullock could win there
you i'm not going to remember all of
them north carolina you've also got
uh maine as you mentioned so yeah i've
outlined
a path that is not it's not
overwhelmingly likely but it's certainly
feasible for democrats to take control
of the senate and you know
when i see a poll that says texas is
tied between trump and biden
that's the type of shift that would
likely go along with
democrats taking control of the senate
but all we can do is get out and vote
and we've got to make sure that we do
that
okay yeah because i i have like the
deepest level of disdain for miss
mitch mcconnell like you suck the trump
evil amy mcgrath and mitch mcconnell is
another example
exactly even even like lindsey graham in
south carolina like i
such deep disdain he's like destroying
our country on purpose
and i like hate that guy so much that if
he lost that power it would be huge for
us
it would be absolutely yeah so don't
forget that's a good one
um lindsey graham has an opponent in
south carolina i believe jeremy harrison
even though certainly it's an uphill
bike
or something there's a lot of races here
that we should be looking at no question
about it fight every single one of them
and it would be amazing
amazing to take control of the senate um
and because
listen if biden wins in november
and senate control remains with
republicans that dramatically limits how
much
biden can get done in terms of major
legislation hopefully he can still use
executive orders to reverse a lot of the
atrocities trump has done
but you're you're going to struggle to
get big legislation done and that's why
taking the senate would be just
fantastic
well yeah and then we can just push and
push and just roll over the republicans
absolutely i mean as i've said before as
i've said before
the other reason progressives should
really want to take the senate
is that we want if joe i don't want to
put the cart before the horse i've
probably said that a dozen times this
week
if joe biden becomes president we want
to be best positioned
to force biden to be as progressive as
possible
if there's a republican senate it's
unlikely biden is going to be tested
with any seriously progressive bills if
the republicans lose the senate
democrats and in the house and senate
will potentially pass
some pretty progressive stuff the senate
is not super progressive even the
democrats in the senate are not the most
progressive people
but we can put stuff on biden's desk
where it's like is he gonna veto that
stuff
that's the the the ideal scenario where
we can
force some stuff onto biden's desk
no yeah exactly exactly that was that
was my big question i'm like a huge fan
of yours
thank you all the videos you're you're
awesome you're smart you make great
points so i just i appreciate it
if you kind of what i'm thinking about
so thank you for your time i'm glad you
called very much appreciate it that is
going to do it for calls
today we we're going to go to a break
but i do plan on taking calls again in
the future if you were unable to get on
today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your chemex or french
press or
a david pakman show t-shirt it's all
available
on our website shipping to anywhere in
the world
at davidpakman.com gear don't miss the
bumper stickers too
davidpakman.com forward slash gear
the david pakman show at david
davidpakman.com
okay let's get into audience questions
this week and there are some good ones
many of you probably saw the letter
published in harper's magazine
signed by more than 150 people
criticizing
a call out culture and cancel culture as
it has become known to many
and i got a bunch of questions
essentially saying can we cancel
or ban cancel culture
maybe by making political beliefs a
protected
class much like nationality or religion
etc
um i mean listen i i think that that's
very very dangerous to do and there's a
couple different reasons why
if you look at religious beliefs being
considered a protected class
that's already problematic now i
understand the basis for
you know if if you need to establish in
all
aspects of the law non-discrimination on
the basis
of religion or lack of religion
then it follows that you probably have
to include religious beliefs as a
protected class but understand that
religious beliefs are self-professed in
other words they're not immutable
saying that you can't discriminate on
the basis of race
or national origin as examples or
disability one has no control over those
characteristics whereas you very much
have control over your religious beliefs
and of course there's the reality that
you know people are born into religion
in many ways but it is different
but the point is to add something like
political belief as a protected class
would create absolute and complete chaos
white supremacy as a value set
would be protected business can't fire
someone or
say they won't serve a customer who
comes in wearing a kkk hood because
those are political beliefs
and if you make political beliefs uh
protected
under the law all of a sudden you are
forced to do business with individuals
uh on in these categories and the
reality is that
it's bs in the sense that it runs
directly counter to everything that
republicans claim to want
it runs directly counter to the idea of
small government
wait a second you think many of them
think
that non-discrimination laws are already
too strict
but they want to add political beliefs
to that list
many of them believe that businesses are
already over-regulated you want
to add another element where businesses
are not free to decide how they're going
to operate their businesses
it is a disastrous idea
and at its core i mean listen we can
have a reasonable debate and i'm glad to
engage in it
about what are productive
and unproductive examples of boycotting
or calling for boycotts
that's a great conversation to have and
there's no one answer to it
and sometimes a boycott or a call for a
cancellation makes sense and sometimes
it doesn't let's figure that out
but the people who were talking about
ban
the epidemic of cancer culture
they don't like that speech has
consequences and that there are new
tools for people to voice their
displeasure like for example social
media
there's really no way to end cancel
culture
without curtailing speech rights
something being a right
the right to speak doesn't mean that it
must be free of ramifications and the
consequences to speech
are speech in and of themselves so no
political uh ideology should not be a
protected class
in fact it might make the problem worse
imagine imagine an employee
says something absolutely insane and
horrifying
and a company can't fire them because
it's their legally protected
political belief now the company has to
keep an employee on
who regularly makes anti-semitic or
racist comments they can't fire them
because those are merely political
beliefs
this is literally the free market we're
talking about here right businesses are
driven by
customer wants and desires if one
customer says i don't want to do
business with you if you have a white
supremacist maybe you ignore it
if you have a white supremacist working
for you if a hundred thousand people say
it then
maybe you evaluate that in the market
and decide
i'd better get rid of this employee of
course assuming that
there's not a contract that keeps the
employee in place or
if it does you have to look at whether
the contract has any kind of clause in
it about unbecoming behavior
right we have a system for this stuff
and simply saying political beliefs are
protected as if they were race or
national origin or disability
uh not a good idea and i would be
against it next question
david i see that joe biden is doing
really well in the polls
what is the point of no return for
donald trump's
polling so let me first give you
the for practical purposes answer
imagine there is no point of no return
even if trump is losing by
20 on november 2nd you go out and you
vote on november 3rd because you just
don't know what's going to happen in
your state we all have to vote
uh etc now i believe that
if on october 1st about a a month before
the election
the numbers are what they are today uh i
believe it's it's over
for donald trump short of a true miracle
we're not talking
think back to 2016. 2016 heading into
election uh
into the election day um the national
polling was hillary is up by 3.2
and hillary won by 2.1 in the national
popular vote of course because of 77 000
votes in three states electorally she
ultimately lost
we're talking about you know an eight to
nine point lead for joe biden
right now and if those are the numbers
um
going into the election joe biden is is
going to win
uh now what could change this listen if
joe biden's indicted between now and
november
um if joe biden dies between now and
november
if trump personally cures cancer on
halloween
right these are the types of things
where if on october 1st biden's up eight
and a half
that's what you need to turn it around
william barr and mitch mcconnell could
try to pull something underhanded you
know maybe some kind of bs investigation
into joe or hunter biden
maybe it would have an impact honestly
at this point i don't even know that
that would make a difference
a lot of people uh would not take it
seriously you know trump's retweeting
chuck woolery while attacking anthony
fauci on the issue of coronavirus
it's clear that trump has lost
credibility with a large swath of the
american electorate each day that trump
doesn't take the lead in the polling
it's a day he loses to turn it around
and um you know i've been getting emails
about should joe biden even bother to
debate trump
the idea now being trump's doing so much
self-inflicted damage
um why would joe biden even come out and
debate
now of course your view on that depends
on how well you think joe biden
would do i i hope they debate i look
forward to watching the debates
but i do think there's a question there
like is it he just just let trump
continue to self-destruct maybe debating
him doesn't even really make sense
although again
if trump is willing and biden is not it
would look bad for joe biden
the other difference i think that's
important in terms of looking at the
polling
in 2016 and looking at the polling today
is that
in 2016 donald trump was running
on being the anti-washington dc guy he
was riding a wave of
anti-establishment sentiment which
may have helped him as hillary clinton
was dogged by the
james comey press conference etc
trump is the establishment right now so
that
is not going to work and in terms of
looking at why trump isn't doing well in
the polls
the leading drag factors for trump are
coronavirus handling economy
racial issues as connected to the george
floyd
protests could those change between now
and november
yeah theoretically i mean coronavirus
could be gotten
more under control right now it's as out
of control as it's been
if that were to happen the economy could
start to turn around
three and a half months is not that long
and we've already been in corona virus
mode for about five months so how likely
that is is a question mark but i would
see the
point of no return as sometime around
october 1st
barring something earth-shattering
earth-shattering like
an indictment of joe biden or again as i
said
trump personally uh secures cancer or
develops a coronavirus vaccine
third question that came in this week
how likely is it that any president is
really going to pack the court and add
seats to the supreme court
so this is an interesting question
because this is often mentioned when any
time we talk about the supreme court
invariably the question comes up about
you know
um if mitch mcconnell is going to
hold the seat for a year so barack obama
can't put in merrick garland and donald
trump gets to put in neil gorsuch
next time there's a democratic president
that person he or she
should just add seats to the supreme
court because you
can do that and that way you know if it
ends up being 7-2
you just add a bunch of justices and all
of a sudden you've got a left-leaning
majority um i think that the risk of
doing it and
and the reason it's not been done
recently
is that if a democratic president were
to add seats to the supreme court
and for example republicans still
control the senate
republicans can hold up the
confirmations
of all of the lower court appointees
most cases never make it to the supreme
court and the lower court
just judges are extremely important
and you could potentially fuel number
one
republicans just obstructing every
single one of your actual selections
and number two every time we have a new
president
they're going to add seats to the
supreme court i just don't know that
that's the right way to go
there's things that need to be changed
for example there should not have been a
mechanism for mitch mcconnell to hold
the seat open that could have been
filled by merrick garland uh
filled with merrick garland by barack
obama for a year
it just shouldn't be allowed to do that
there should be you know some
some process and you can think of 10
different ways that it could be done
where that's not possible
we could potentially be looking at
ending lifetime appointments for supreme
court justices now i know that there are
good arguments on both sides
one of them being if a supreme court
justice is
to be truly independent they must not
have
on their minds even subconsciously the
possibility
that they may work in an industry
after they are out of the supreme court
where they are adjudicating a case and
that may be a factor and how
i get that but there's probably ways to
deal with that
which would solve the issue of lifetime
appointments where you're essentially
waiting for people to die or to be so
uh elderly that they can't do the job
anymore
and the timing of i mean it's a very
ugly system in a sense
so i don't you know i know that it's
discussed quite a bit
i don't expect donald trump to pack the
supreme court if he wins a second term
i don't expect joe biden to add supreme
court justices
if he were to defeat donald trump in
november it's a fraught and complicated
issue that requires more exploration
but i do think there are other changes
that should be made to the supreme court
that would not necessarily lead to this
just
persistent race to the bottom or race to
the top or every time you get a new
president they say
let's add two and i'll select them and
of course again if you don't have
control of the senate
the other party could block your
selections to those new seats as well
so complicated issue i would love to
hear your thoughts on it
we will have a fantastic bonus show for
you today
if you've not yet had the pleasure of
watching or listening to the
award-winning bonus show
grab a membership at joinpakman.com